people come to me in shackles just take
me I've done the hard work the cage is
back there just put me you know love has
taken me to some pretty dark places but
Los Angeles has got to be as dark as it
gets
so season two first of all just how
would you describe it cuz everybody's so
excited right is that a tough question
darker gory er more dangerous I mean I
guess it is those things I guess yeah it
is those things but I feel like
ultimately in terms of those devices the
gore the darkness it's it's it's the
same show in a good way like you know
what you're getting but really what's
different is are these two characters
these two women Candice and love they
they represent something that basically
was absent from the first season in
Candice you have the irrefutable fact
that Joe's a murderer
right I love no one likes to call him
out everyone loves to say stalker
he's not just a stalker so we have
Candice who was just basically to him
this mystifying impossible you know it's
like how do how is she because how am I
like I don't understand that so he's got
to grapple with that hello you love it's
nice to meet you love
and then love the character of love who
is essentially the polar opposite of
Beck in that she wants to be with Joe
he's not pursuing her in the same way
it's it's it is a different dynamic so
the fact that he is a predator the fact
that he is delusional has all these
different sort of manic compulsions
they're all just challenged in it I
think in a very different way so so you
see him struggling with himself I hope
in a new in a new way Candice is back
what can fans expect from that she
really shakes him up right yeah I mean I
feel like even just in the first episode
you see him
I had a level of what's the word it's
not just disturbed he's like it's like
more than disturbed I you know I just
like the the way that I make Joe grapple
with Candice is is sort of like is sort
of like like like he's suffering the
world's most unjust persecution I mean
it's you know that's not the case what
do you want Candice
you did it again didn't you look I know
people tweet you this stuff like want
you to kidnap me did they say that in
real life or people coming up to you
please give him out people come to me in
shackles just take me already I've done
the hard work the cage is back there
just put me if fans are gonna tweet you
sometimes responded what should they
tweet you what might catch your eye this
time you usually correct them hey he's a
murderer yeah well you know I think I'm
not sure I think I'm gonna tweak my
approach cuz I didn't I didn't ever mean
to be correcting people you know in that
way like I didn't mean but um it was it
was interesting I think the the media
response last year was very interesting
to see and I'm actually to me the whole
point of this show is that it has to be
like just it is this viral kind of thing
so it it's this conversation piece this
social experiment so I'm not sure
because last time I did it I literally
like was sipping on a coffee
and like shot some tweets often six
minutes and then suddenly it was like
this viral thing and then it yeah so I
mean you know okay this time two coffees
at this point do people come up to you
more for Gossip Girl fandom or for you
obsession Joe is challenging Dan's
legacy I'll say that pretty quickly
she'll pick me up at 8:00 you really go
out with some guy you don't know well
you can't be worse than the guys I do
know
well Gossip Girl is getting a new life
could Dan Humphreys get a new life could
we see him up here at all could Dan
Humphrey I don't you know that's again
these things are I that's a that's a
that's a message I got to put at the top
of my inbox you know because it's to
think about I've not had conversations
with any of the traitors would you be
willing to bring Dan Humphrey back I
think it's pretty clear that like I've
never been necessarily the greatest
friend or fan of Dan Humphrey which now
I reconcile in this way that I'm like
you know I would love to contribute in a
meaningful way to it and I guess we just
it would just depend on a lot of things
would depend on how and why he's there
and I don't know like yeah that would be
the show does come out pretty close to
the holidays we just want you to give
the fans some advice how do you binge it
how do you keep the holiday spirit up do
you watch it with family get them
through just have a lot of water nearby
a lot of vitamin C get the right amount
of sleep you know I mean I know we love
to binge but
[Music]